[Music]
do you guys get a lot of pleasure or
enjoyment oh yeah this faction yeah or
an ego boost all over Adam you guys
getting interaction on social media no
no no no no I do you do yeah I like
engaging with my face
I like engaging with them but I don't
get like pleasure like you know somebody
pull something like whether it's
something has a [ __ ] ton of likes or
very little likes it doesn't really
affect me because what I want to put out
there is what I want to put out yeah I'm
not really doing it for the likes versus
I've seen people were like oh no this
one has so many oh how did it drop so
low like yeah no it's not it's not today
it's more so like I like when I post the
video and the fans find other things
that are funny and I black box
[ __ ] bag and now you would go back and
forth and then other people jump in the
conversations I like that I'm [ __ ]
fat they'd be so [ __ ] funny do the
comments sometimes crack me the [ __ ] up
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I should have
thought of that for the caption yes I
know exactly what you mean I'll be like
[ __ ] that's it take it down and redo it
this is great that's why people out
there don't know their own potential and
that's why we're all successful thank
you they don't know this thank you thank
you for doubting yourself thank you for
not trying it be motivating or so lucky
there's a new app it's called botnet and
this is a social network simulator where
you are the only human along with
millions of bots who are obsessed with
you yeah it sounds like a mom that is so
crazy they're like if you're tired of
your mom being the only one to like your
stuff go on botnet so here's an example
now you got 20 moms so you can know what
it feels like to pretty much go viral
yeah so this one example it says hey
everyone it's me Randall I just set up
my botnet and I'm excited to hang with
you all it has four hundred and seventy
three thousand seven hundred and seven
like oh [ __ ] and some of the comments
because they're BOTS
they don't really make sense so like the
the
first one here it says I'm so proud of
you and hope you're able to find a good
job ah the other one says that is one
happy looking dog and the other one says
I thought I was the only one there is a
point though where there's too many damn
comments have you ever got try to go
through like there's an enjoyable amount
where there's certain times when it's
like you post something and if it's
under 100 it's an enjoyable amount of
comments and you're like great
interaction right but when it gets to
that thousand mark is just you're just
just it the importance of everything
just blends because I do enjoy Instagram
comments because sometimes some funny
[ __ ] comes out of a photo right
sometimes videos too when I'm searching
through the comments it's like oh that
was funny I didn't even notice that like
don't find a [ __ ] booger on a wall at
like time spam three minutes [ __ ] that
some people who will go through [ __ ]
a thousand two thousand comments not
even kidding
yeah max is like 500 and that's like
because I know that it's not 500 comics
like some people are gonna out of that
500 at least 150 are gonna be just
emojis yeah but after a while doesn't it
doesn't it blend and lose its
significance because it's just like I
can't [ __ ] look at all these letters
yeah sometimes I kind of scroll for the
ones that had the most likes - lets see
what they're talking about and then
that's good at now like respond back to
that to keep it going but yeah at that
certain point it does like lose the
thrill for me I usually am trolling and
so I always look for my real fans like
the people who really know what I'm
doing and then there's always the people
who don't have no idea how cuz you
attract a lot of trolls ah yeah yeah
yeah so I go I look for the people who
know what I'm doing I'm like you're the
real you guys are really my people but
then the other people is you're a troll
don't you aren't the other people like
your bread and butter is your actual
yeah yeah no no I need them for sure but
it's but it's but the people that give
me delightful you're talking about the
joy it comes from the people who really
cuz they know what you're really doing
they think they know what you're doing
because one
you know you really do and 10 million
filters yep
no I don't use filters oh sorry though
so you know when people so you know of
these people that like literally read
every [ __ ] promise what have you
observed them and seen like what do they
do cuz I feel like we're not words
we're in social media but we're not we
know those but we'd stay away from them
these are the [ __ ] out of me right no
it's not that though I feel bad for them
it's more like a pity thing it's like
validation it's not pity because I see
myself so much better than them I just
feel bad that they need that validation
so much that they have to go through all
that [ __ ]
have you watched them go through the CIA
yeah so what is that like I want to live
through you um this is years ago but
yeah basically it's like you watch
somebody's throwing a little too much
and then they're kind of internalizing
things while there's crawling let's open
up about what they still do and you're
like damn dude really like you really
care that much about that but by the way
it's not invalid that they feel that way
it's just crazy to see yeah that's the
point and that they will fully partake
in it damn part it's crazy
Doughboy will comment read the comments
on the live that we do like we were it
was me him and care and we were having a
conversation about if somebody I wipe
her to say in the N word and Doughboy I
said this is live - he's like I already
cares about you oh my god calls me an
idiot
like like it's all in their tent that he
doesn't know this type of stuff
and it was like wow like they started
going in you know cancelled oh boy put
two here on us oh I thought you said
white people that finally felt liberated
went in and just said Edward Edward
Edward no no so but don't boy we'll go
through and reach one of those comments
knowing what you just said was like it
was inciting a riot and now you're
you're filling some time away because
they told you how they felt about the
foolishness that you said and he becomes
a prisoner of that moment like a really
[ __ ] me all of they're like well
you're influencing people listen to what
you say they believe that it has
validity to it and so when you say
something like that which is kind of
productive of everything that we've
tried to work for it progressively as a
as a race and you say I don't care if
you come in there you don't bother me
we're like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about the way I'll say this right now
I've said this forever I I think people
anybody has the right to say what are
the [ __ ] they want but then everybody
has the right to judge it however the
[ __ ] exact that's all it was just like
that uh the video of the rapper
there was a white battle rapper he was
rapping against his black dude and he
said he literally started the ball with
they said I can't say the n-word in this
battle why my [ __ ] he was gonna say I
just caught your bluff
but soon as he said well my [ __ ] by
hitting the mouth
it's the Karma immediately no time
wasted instantly he didn't get the a out
what my mic's right there this boy has
to step up and push either guy back but
his boy with a black doing I was just
like you to be in the room I'm like cuz
that's your boy so you want to protect
your boy but it's also like my race so
like he just let go I wish somebody
would've just yelled off slavery
but it's like like in that moment like
Doughboy didn't take it into
consideration it's not just you that you
speaking for in that moment right
because there are y'all got thousands of
people watching you live right now and
you're speaking on your behalf which is
cool you should have that freedom but
just know that people are going to judge
you off of that especially something as
sensitive yes especially something that
sensitive is that and you know it's a
word that we've tried of taking the
power back and some of the staying away
from but the history is still there
listen any Bravo right is a is Joe
Rogan's buddy but but my point is that
he's a platter so he's a flat earth so
that woody when I say Eddie Bravo you
think flat earther he brought that on
himself
it's like that by talking openly about
fighters so so when you hear Eddie Bravo
he just answered my answer exactly my
flat earther and that
you say master there are consequences to
you saying certain things you just deal
with it you can say whatever the [ __ ]
you want right deal with it is freedom
of speech it's just not freedom from
consequence all done social perception
or whatever they're gonna believe but if
your own botnet you have freedom of
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say
because they go nice because botnet you
said they say nice things to you
they have said that they do not save any
of your information so whatever you say
it's like going into the void and these
bots will respond and it will not make
sense but are you a racist things would
they respond back to you with those
words hey cool I love you to work I mean
another one said like another example
says lady at the post office called me
ugly and then someone responds that's a
terrible idea
and another one says I'm glad your pup
is okay oh my god so sweet I love her
smile well it's just a random [ __ ] oh I
thought they took the words that you
said and repeated it that'd be smart
yeah I don't think they have an
algorithm for guessing Google [ __ ] like
they do a little bit because here's
another response so it was lady at the
post office called me ugly the response
says I thought you were going to send me
back to the post office with your dog so
they did use post office hmm are people
gonna get the same satisfaction though
if they're screaming into the void and
because one of the satisfaction is
knowing that real people like your stuff
for our common team no but now it's just
all a bunch of views it's like it's like
making a post and then having your
friend that's a graphic designer put a
million views on it you know and then
you let me get that back but it's also I
think it's similar to people who play
Sims and minecraft and Bill teased all
of these world yes and the same thing is
people who bout fans about fans or
subscribers and just have that number of
like it might just be a gratification
thing to think that that many people
like what you say of value what you say
or people that buy subscription from a
cowgirl yeah and they have a
relationship with them and they don't
they know it's fake but they still
thought it was like it's hard to fake
but then they're like a monster they're
still into it
now what was this about what cam girl
cancer not a real relationship right but
people I mean we live in this world now
where reality is all [ __ ] up and it's
like twisted oh yeah like so yeah like
oh but if a bot is saying some [ __ ] to
you or whatever is like some people
might even enjoy that because they
they're not getting any anything yeah
that's exactly the point I think because
like some of these pose like I mentioned
before they have like over hundreds of
thousands of likes and interaction like
all the comments even though they don't
make sense like for people that just get
that gratification I don't like I'm
important even though it's not real yeah
this is for them Wow - what Doughboy was
saying mmm when you hear louis c.k
saying the N word in his bit what do you
think of that what's your take on that
you can say what you want but there will
be consequences
I'm not the hugest louis c.k fan how
back see never even seeing him say it
because I haven't I don't watch a
stand-up like that he did a very clever
way yeah I find it you know interesting
that we see how other people reacted
like to find somebody like a Chris Rock
who thinks it's okay for louis c.k to do
it I would want to see him in a
situation where I ran the white person
said it and then kind of judged off his
character because I feel like it's a
word that is reserved like for those
communities and this is what I said on
the podcast it's like I've seen gay guys
call each other the f-word back and
forth I've seen women engaged in common
said in conversation calling each other
[ __ ] back and forth that's their
community I would not have a
conversation with a female black man if
you ain't gonna believe I would do it
jokingly with one of my homeboys but I
wouldn't call it female like I miss you
you ain't like that's it's not my
community I'm not engulfed in that
enough I don't know all the I'm aware of
some of their the gripes in their their
hurdles but I'm not in there so I don't
feel comfortable expressing that time of
a different the way they use it the same
way with the LGBTQ community
gay guys call each other [ __ ] I know
they do they call each other [ __ ]
they also call each other that word but
that's their community and I respect the
fact that I'm not in that community well
enough to call them that because that's
their term of endearment
so [ __ ] is like our term of a different
we took that
from a place of disparity and Indus
everything hearts and horrible about the
early centuries of this country and
turned it into something that we can
greet each other with we can call each
other out on check the paragraph it's a
lot so but that's in our community yeah
people use it who are outside of that
community just know that you're at risk
of offending somebody who looks as that
word is something more than just a work
that's why it's not funny to me cuz I
lose the keys business very smart very
good but it's just when I hear it you
focus on the word more than the bit it
takes away for now chronic so that's why
I wouldn't use it in doing ass in a bit
even though I believe in language and
just freedom so yeah but [ __ ] dude if it
takes the audience out of the joke then
you're [ __ ] up especially right now I
believe that there isn't a concept of
consensus in the black community with
the word mmm because some people say
don't use it at all right yes say it's
cool but just for us alright ever right
but I remember in the 90s
almost everyone said it yeah like
everyone but not to make it okay yeah
but also in the 90s everyone wasn't
online yeah if we grew up together and
we've been friends for like 20 years or
whatever that's different
come here and if a black guy doesn't
know me
and I use it like we're homies there's
no report right it's like what the [ __ ]
don't say that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] of
like there's um there's there's like
this monolithic culture where it's like
hey Bart your agent you speak for all
Asians right now hey to hear you're
speaking for all black you right now
like it's a bunch of [ __ ] it is it
depends on the relationship that you
have with that person yeah and because
everything's online now yeah I just stay
away from the word everyone should stay
away from it because it's not your word
to own or say white people are not the
only people who are multi-dimensional
who can have different opinions about
things well yeah like women men black
people white people Asian people okay
straight they all have different [ __ ]
opinions that's the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah but the fact that people don't
think that and I go well you're a woman
how can you think that yeah that's a
weird [ __ ] blows mine
[Music]